it is a shame but doesn't take away or
diminish the good that darren waller and
his donors did last night
raising thousands for the kids of
southern nevada kevin martin has more on
darren's good deed
i know there are a lot of kids out there
that are like me take one look at darren
waller and you'll see a strong and
confident figure
but it wasn't always that way for the
raiders 6-6 tight end
you know sensitive just trying to fit in
trying to be cool and would
do anything to try to achieve those
things waller has been very open
about his past drug and alcohol abuse
and has now made it a mission to help
lead young adults in the right direction
i just want to let them know that they
don't have to go the path of using drugs
or alcohol to do that they can be
themselves they can
bet on themselves and know that the end
results are going to be something they
can love and respect
on monday night waller held his first
ever beyond the wall gala
with proceeds from the event benefiting
the darren waller foundation
yeah the funds go to educating them
number one letting them know statistics
letting them know
information on what could happen if you
choose to go down that path go money
goes to creating an online community
for kids to you know have an honest safe
space for them to have open dialogue
talk about things that they're going
through
and just to not talk down that youth but
to let them know that i'm with them and
that i've kind of been through the
strokes that they've been through so
those are the three of the main things
and then working towards
funding treatment a little further down
the road waller can't wait to have a
positive
impact on the youth right here in las
vegas i just want to get in front of
them let them know that
you know you don't have to be anything
outside of yourself to be able to do
special things if i can do it why can't
you
covering the raiders in las vegas i'm
kevin martin